SETH LADD: Hi.
Welcome to this Dart
Q&A on GDL.
My name is Seth Ladd.
I'm a developer advocate
with the Chrome team.
And we're joined here today
with two special guests--
Gilad Bracha, Dart language spec
lead, and JJ Behrens, a
developer advocate joining
with the Dart
team very soon, actually.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, very
excited about that.
SETH LADD: Very cool.
Well, we kind of have a short
amount of time. here.
So we're going to get to it and
answer all these questions
that you had in our moderator
for this GDL session.
So right at the top, did they
find the Higgs boson today?
Gilad.
GILAD BRACHA: I didn't
follow that.
SETH LADD: Oh, it
just came out.
GILAD BRACHA: But they
would have done it.
If they'd used Dart, they'd
have done it faster.
SETH LADD: Absolutely.
Well, I think they're going to
announce that coming up soon,
so that's good.
GILAD BRACHA: Cool.
SETH LADD: First adopter,
there you go.
Oh, wait that's not on the--
sorry, OK, the moderator says,
Golgote from Paris.
"I'd like to develop apps
for Android but
I'm allergic to Java.
Is there any chance to see
Google eat its own dog food
someday and provide a complete
Android SDK for Dart?"
Well, we're not on
the Android team.
We're part of the Dart team,
which is on Chrome.
We've heard this
request a lot.
But I know that the Dart project
is focused squarely on
making a fantastic development
experience
for modern web apps.
JJ BEHRENS: And that would
extend to all the mobile
devices, not just Android, as
much as we love Android.
But we'd like to work
everywhere.
SETH LADD: Excellent point.
We're all modern browsers.
John E from Texas asks, "I'd
love to hear more about the
roadmap to bring Dart closer to
the Google API ecosystem."
Well, some good news there.
You probably see an API console
or explorer that
Google has for a countless
number of APIs.
We are working on easy ways to
integrate your Dart app with
our API services.
So we're still working
on that.
But we will make it easier for
you to plug into the existing
Google API set, like YouTube,
I think, right?
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, I love that
new API infrastructure, where
you could have all the different
APIs kind of behave
in similar ways.
And have one client library
to rule them all.
SETH LADD: Yes.
So we're definitely
working on that.
We hear your call.
This fine gentleman Seth Ladd
writes, "I remember when Dart
was first announced,
it generated a lot
of JavaScript code.
What's the latest on the Dart to
JavaScript compiler?" Have
you been following
that at all?
GILAD BRACHA: Well, we've been
moving to this new compiler.
Dart to JS, which is actually
essentially, even though the
project's very young, the third
generation of our Dart
to JavaScript compiler.
I know they're working
on that.
They're not where they want to
be yet, in some ways, because
we're getting the
semantics right.
It's actually getting, in some
ways, a little bit worse in
some cases.
But Kasper's on it, and I'm
confident that these numbers
will keep improving over time.
JJ BEHRENS: So, Gilad, I know
that we're always talking
about this weird thing
called tree shaking.
And I know we have a lot of tree
huggers here at Google,
but I'm pretty sure that's not
what we're talking about.
GILAD BRACHA: Right, so this is
basically in the interest
of minimizing the amount of code
that gets shipped down to
the browser.
In your program, if you do an
analysis, you can often find
that the tree-- the abstract
syntax tree, basically, that
you parse for your program--
contains lots of pieces
that you're not
actually going to use.
And so you want to shake the
tree and get them to fall off
so that you can ship
less code.
So it's a way of basically
reducing the code size.
SETH LADD: I'd actually take
that and segue into a new
feature that we've working
on a long time.
Mirrors, which is, I guess, the
Dart way to do reflection.
But I think there's an
interesting intersection there
with tree shaking.
Is that right?
GILAD BRACHA: Right.
Reflection makes--
well, they make each other
harder, basically.
But basically what happens is
if you're doing reflection,
you may have code that you're
calling reflectively that the
static analysis can't find.
And so either it can't tree
shake, which is bad because
your code will grow.
Or you may find that you had
this thing you were going to
reflect on that was written in
your file but didn't get
shipped down to the browser.
And so we're going to have
mechanisms to let you say
that, even though this isn't
statically in my code, I
expect this to not
be shaken away.
The exact nature of that
mechanism is still being
debated, but we're aware
of the problem.
It's one of many.
It makes life interesting.
JJ BEHRENS: Great.
SETH LADD: Moving back to the
moderator, Hussain writes,
"When will we see a Dart VM
as a flag in Chrome and
ChromeOS?"
JJ BEHRENS: Oh, that's
exciting.
SETH LADD: Well, we have a Dart
virtual machine in what
we affectionately call Dartium
today, which ships as part of
our editor download.
And this is a build of Chromium
with the Dart VM
embedded right in it.
And so you can run your Dart
programs directly inside a
build of Chromium.
So we're on track.
And it's part of the plan to
ship Dart VM inside of Chrome.
When?
It's hard to tell.
But the best thing you can do
to help make that happen is
download the editor, play with
Dartium, and help us get there
even faster.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, I know that
when they initially hired me
onto the Dart team, part of the
reason they hired me is
I'm a fairly big guy.
I'm a lot bigger
than you guys.
And I think that's going to
be helpful in case any
PMs get in our way.
SETH LADD: OK, "Will there be
a Dart UI control library
similar to maybe Closure
Library, Ext JS?" Yes, we have
definitely on the roadmap this
concept of a UI library.
The final form is yet
to be worked out.
We're still working
hard on that.
But the Dart project does
come batteries included.
That's definitely the vision.
And so you can kind of work
yourself up from language spec
to virtual machine to the
libraries to the runtimes.
But then you have the kind of
userland libraries, like a UI
library to help you write
those web apps.
So it's definitely
on the roadmap.
This one I actually hear
numerous times.
"I'd like to develop Dart
modular web applications with
a low initial load time.
Do you plan to support lazy
loading of Dart libraries, or
is there any other way
to accomplish this?"
GILAD BRACHA: There will be
a way to accomplish it.
Now, lazy loading actually
encompasses a
multitude of things.
And it's not clear that you'll
have a completely general,
arbitrary lazy loading,
at least not
without using fancy mirrors.
But definitely the issue of
efficient loading of web apps
is very high on our list.
And there's going to be
a good story for that.
The details are still
a little murky.
SETH LADD: TBD.
JJ BEHRENS: Gilad, tell me a
little bit more about how
Dart's going to make web apps
start up a lot faster once we
get the Dart VM integrated
into the browser.
GILAD BRACHA: OK, so the basic
idea is that we have this
mechanism called snapshots.
And they let you--
even in the current
stage, which I
expect will get better--
load a program 10x faster than
by loading Dart code over the
network, where you have
to parse it and all
that kind of stuff.
So that translates very
directly into
good startup times.
JJ BEHRENS: Great, because
I'm very impatient.
SETH LADD: Yes.
Another question here, going on.
"Will Dart to JavaScript
compiler take advantage of
ECMAscript 6 improvements like
class support in order to make
generated code even smaller?"
GILAD BRACHA: I think
it would.
SETH LADD: When it rolls out?
GILAD BRACHA: I'm sure that
whenever that stuff is
available in the target browsers
and so forth, where
it's useful to use it,
it'll get used.
That specifically, there are
probably differences between
ECMAscript classes and Dart
classes, so it may be a little
naive to focus on that one.
We will have to look at
it and figure it out.
But generally, anything that
gets into JavaScript that
makes it easier for us, we
will suck their blood and
leverage it to the hilt.
JJ BEHRENS: Do you think that
there will be cases where we
hold back on some of those newer
features of JavaScript
to ensure that we work
really well with
slightly older browsers?
You know, ones that have
JavaScript but maybe aren't
quite as cutting edge?
GILAD BRACHA: Well,
I think so.
So we're targeting
modern browsers.
Now, that's modern now.
If they have to be more modern
in order to run some of this
stuff, we might not want to
get that modern that fast.
Depending how--
this is something you just
see-- what's deployed out
there, what you can bank
on-- and make it
up as you go along.
SETH LADD: I think this is
actually an excellent case on
something that Dart brings
to the table today.
That is that the
class syntax--
I find it very hard today to
integrate code from different
libraries in JavaScript.
You have MooTools has their
own kind of class builder.
And you have Ext JS has
a class builder.
And never the twain shall
meet, in a sense.
And when you bake class
semantics into the language,
now I can share stuff
across these
frameworks and libraries.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah.
SETH LADD: Dart enables me to
do that today, which I'm
looking forward to.
So this is a good one I hear a
lot. "I'd like to see Dart
support in Google App Engine.
Will you enable this
scenario?"
JJ BEHRENS: Hmm.
Dart works on client and server,
but App Engine--
I don't know if we've thought
about that one yet.
SETH LADD: Well, there's
an existing bug for it.
JJ BEHRENS: Is there?
SETH LADD: I think in the App
Engine bug issue tracker.
So definitely go there
and star that.
It's not the first time I've
heard that either, and so
that'd be kinda cool.
OK, we've got a couple
minutes to wrap up.
Let's see--
oh, this is one that
comes up a lot.
"When can we see a two-way
communication between
JavaScript and Dart so that the
rich features of existing
JavaScript libraries and
frameworks can be exploited?"
Now, I think we want to
do this generally.
But how does this impact the
overall design of the system?
GILAD BRACHA: Well, it's rather
complicated because
garbage collectors don't
like each other.
They're sort of alpha
kind of things.
They just won't--
it's very hard to have two
VMs tightly coupled.
So the way we've envisaged
doing this is through the
isolate mechanism.
And that, at the moment, is
still a little painful because
of the asynchrony.
But there's thoughts about
making synchronous covers for
this that should make it
relatively painless.
JJ BEHRENS: Now, that'd actually
be really nice, to be
able to have multiple
widgets on the page.
And have them protected via
isolate, so that people can't
reach in and monkey
with my stuff.
And keep me a little
bit safer.
GILAD BRACHA: Well,
that's the idea.
SETH LADD: We should chat--
so you mentioned isolates.
We should probably talk
just a second about
what isolates are--
isolated memory heaps.
It allows you to do a couple of
different cool use cases.
For one, the security use case
that you're talking about.
Another one-- it allows you to
exploit multi-core systems
once you have separated memory
heaps in your runtime.
You could run those concurrently
or on a pool of
processes or threads.
And then there's the interop
potential use case as well.
Can I use isolates to
communicate between, say,
JavaScript and Dart?
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, whenever I try
to explain this, I always
try to say actors.
But then, of course, if you know
what an actor, you don't
need to ask this question.
GILAD BRACHA: And the other
great thing is, of course,
Dart on the server and Dart on
the client should eventually
be talking through isolates,
through message passing, and
not through browser-specific
mechanisms.
That may take a little
while, but--
SETH LADD: Absolutely.
I've heard that.
GILAD BRACHA: --that
should make life
much cleaner and simpler.
SETH LADD: So I've always
wondered what the-- so I guess
the wrap-up last question here,
"What are some of the
design constraints for
the Dart language.
That is, what's that box
you're working in?"
GILAD BRACHA: It's a very small
box because it has to
compile efficiently
to JavaScript.
And it has to be sort of
palatable to a large body of
mainstream developers, both from
the Java world and the
JavaScript world.
And that's actually a pretty
hard set of constraints.
SETH LADD: Well, I know I've
really enjoyed it.
In fact, true story-- one day
I was editing Dart code.
I had no idea it
was Dart code.
It was so familiar.
I just pulled up the file, and
I didn't even know it.
So good job on the
familiarity.
With that, I think.
I want to thank our guests
today, JJ and Gilad.
We'll be at Google I/O next
week to give a bunch of
different Dart talks and chat
with developers there.
And if you can't be there, we'll
hold more of these cool
GDL sessions and more
Q&As, and--
lots of ways to get
ahold of us.
So I guess lastly, join our Dart
mailing list if you're
interested in learning more.
And we're going to be there to
help out, answer questions.
And thanks for watching.
And thanks for trying Dart.
JJ BEHRENS: Thanks a lot, guys.